everyday people the world over use
plastic shopping bags they're
lightweight hard-wearing and often come
for free
but how harmful are plastic bags to the
climate every year more than 600 billion
plastic bags are manufactured worldwide
four percent of the crude oil consumed
globally every year ends up in plastic
bags but oil is a fossil fuel and
supplies are slowly coming to an end
manufacturing and shipping plastic bags
requires large amounts of energy and
also causes sixty tons of co2 emissions
every year on average plastic bags are
in use for just 25 minutes then they're
thrown away few of them are recycled
most plastic bags end up in rivers on
the streets or in the ocean and they're
tough some will take 500 years to
disintegrate that is if they aren't
eaten by wild animals plastic bags are
life threatening for wildlife
some countries have banned plastic bags
entirely while in others it's illegal to
give them away for free
but the best way to help the climate is
to use alternatives and forget plastic
bags altogether